citizens of the reject Nation it's
meteor Erickson alongside my friend say
your name I'm Aaron hello full name
Alexander thank you find you Aaron today
we're gonna watch Saul and neither of us
have seen it saw you have not seen it
I've never seen a single saw I never saw
a saw oh my goodness he never saw saw
that's sad because I've been to Home
Depot seen many listen guys you gotta
leave a like you gotta type in your
computer you gotta leave a comment and
you guys know you got a ring now
[Music]
also guys thanks to
uh prepper for the edit yep and also
don't forget to uh become the Patriots
you can watch the full length Reaction
watch along with your own copy and be a
part of the super sexy reject Nation you
guys know how that goes and if you don't
know how it goes you just get on patreon
and then you're like oh now I see how it
goes Greg and John also cover several
shows exclusively over there with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included so you know get over there do
the business I haven't slept in four
days because I've been doing an
overnight shoot so if this seems clunky
that's why okay you got anything to say
about saw or my performance here today
Aaron uh I think you're killing it four
days of no sleep yeah overnight shoots
you guys so right now I'm on and off
schedule are we ready to watch Saw I
feel like oh yeah we're ready I can't
say F-bomb
foreign
[Music]
yeah okay
the dude from Princess Bride yes oh wow
and recognize him about his mustache
Shane I don't think that's gonna work I
thought it would be helpful Chief yeah
if you get like a little flame and just
like keep it there maybe I've seen that
in a movie Once what's your name my name
is very [__] confused what's your
name what's going on here my name is
Lawrence Gordon
I just woke up here just like you you're
way too calm about this for a guy just
woke up yeah except I feel like he was
the guy talking in the dark
um okay what's the last thing you
remember I went to bed in my [__]
apartment and woke up in an actual
[__] I was on my way home from Mark
and I don't remember anything else you
gonna tell me your name Adam that clock
somebody obviously wanted us to know the
time interesting yeah weird
where'd you find it
it's in my pocket doesn't that guy in
the ground have a tape recorder he does
have a tape recorder yeah
a little snap to be getting into it now
getting into it we're starting to cook
there's your life
[Laughter]
but who gets to play it first and a
bullet and there's a gun oh snap
someone's gonna kill someone God they're
gonna have to choose
I bet used to the door throw it over
here
foreign
I mean what's he gonna do right I mean
well I have the one bullet he doesn't
have a bullet right
oh God are they gonna be like each one
of them Out Of Reach of that oh that's
terrible how
what
are you sure oh your shirt oh
yes okay so I thought he fell asleep
like that or the whoever kidnapped them
and put the shirts on right put clothes
on them
take him outside the box God also but
that guy has a the other one has a blue
shirt on and he could be reaching for
the gun and he is a bullet he could yeah
he has an undershirt on
it must be something a dirty ass bathtub
that's right he woke up in that it's a
dream stopper
it is a dream oh yeah
oh nice getting close
I got it nice
or I'll tell you where you might be you
might be in the room that you die in I
am scared to see what this tape says
someone angry yet empathetic but mostly
just pathetic so you're going to watch
yourself die today Adam
Gordon you have given people
that they're gonna die soon now you will
need a cause of death your aim in this
game is to kill her until six on the
clock to do what until what oh my God if
you do not kill Adam by six then Allison
and Diana will die last one Allison and
Diana this is awkward
the game began
what follow your heart oh [__] that
means kill Adam because his heart was
with his family x marks the spot though
also
um
poopy heart
oh this is where the key comes in huh
maybe oh God yes thank you oh my God
please no
I can
[Music]
nope nope nope nope
oh
[Music]
my God why oh God oh so y'all better not
make me vomit in a room nobody told me
this movie was sponsored by Taco Bell oh
[__] oh [__]
[Laughter]
please let it be something normal
oh my god oh title of the movie
oh and they both have one two saws God
yeah I mean it's like God there is no
you're gonna run you're gonna like
they're gonna make the saw not useful
anymore
yeah dum dum dummy dum dum dum
through our feet only one of you can now
I think I may know who's done this to us
really oh it's not someone I know
personally it's just someone I know of
oh last I heard police still hadn't
caught him the only reason I know that
is because I was a suspect oh I know
that guy yeah he looks so young right
Danny Glovers okay
oh what the hell is going on here yo
victims of 46 year old male
died of massive blood loss oh that's
rough oh that's yeah it's gross he
started at the back of the Cajun
tunneled his way through that razor wire
so fast it's amazing he got as far as he
did oh wow we also found this
what Bud Light oh no oh it's a tape okay
look like a can for a second you want to
die you just have to stay where you are
but if you want to live you'll have to
cut yourself again
he's alive at three o'clock that door
will lock and then this room becomes
your tomb oh no it's watching flashback
he was given two hours
oh my God
the jigsaw killer technically speaking
easy
not really a murderer oh right he's just
like setting he finds ways for his
victims to kill themselves interesting
selling traps if you're so sick then why
do I have so many photos of you up and
about there's a slow acting poison in
your veins the antidote is inside the
safe combination to the safe
history on the wall oh but watch your
step
that's a flammable substance smeared on
your body oh God just might have their
Revenge oh my goodness freaking gracious
wow
awful looks like our friend jigsaw likes
to book himself front row seats to his
own sick little games he left us his pen
right does he want to be found this
patient has an inoperable frontal lobe
tumor extending across the midline
started as colon cancer the patient had
his name is John
oh this guy from Lost yeah it's a very
interesting person thank you for that
information
orderly's form very special bonds with
the patience give me sus Vibes guy
obviously someone doesn't want me to
tell you what the patient has excuse me
girl you're in school right now
are you able to tell us where you were
between the hours of 11 pm and 1am
why is it that you're interested you
[__] around with that girl
it's best if we do it down at the
station that's quite
I can't just leave I
have my wife has oh he's a cheater too
this is your doctor oh so the killer was
a patient maybe like and he told him
you're gonna die right and that and the
guy he must have taken his pen look if
you can't be honest with me I was
visiting someone it wasn't a patient I
was cheating on my wife I checked your
Alibi it holds up we have one of the
victims who managed to escape want to
know if you wouldn't mind sticking
around and listening to her testimony
this man's wearing a jean jacket for a
blazer
[Laughter]
he's ahead of his time he's ahead of his
time
the first thing you remember
I woke up
I could taste was blood oh my God
oh spooky
ripped
oh my God
I'll show you no don't do that no no I
don't like it
oh the demonstration is so unnecessary
there was only one key
device
soulmate
ugh
[Music]
yeah girl meddle it out
oh my God no ah but her mouth was
bleeding in the room
[Music]
I don't want it she did it she when
she's there yeah but is her mouth weird
it's a little weird and then I saw the
body
that person don't look dead to me
[Music]
did you have to cut the question mark oh
God
oh my God oh my God
he's alive oh my god
[Music]
oh she's doing it oh but it's definitely
not in the shape of a question mark
she's just going at it you didn't follow
the lines no you're supposed to trace oh
you killed the you killed that guy you
killed the poop out of that guy oh
oh
crap oh God
seems like she got it light compared to
the other ones oh yeah he's just gonna
have to live with those memories forever
yeah okay maybe she didn't
oh boy what is that keeps going
should be over she should have escaped
what is this what's going on
oh that's terrifying a puppet on a
tricycle why is it like that why is it
sweating oh God
all right
not anymore why are you moist
oh and
that is why he picked you
you sting why is he picking the people
he's picking
he helped me
they say helped her
no you either tell me what is really
going on or I'll cut you with this you
hear me
oh
oh is it two-way glass
camera
okay
part of me feels like that body's not
dead that's what I was gonna say because
the other one wasn't and I'm like but
can a dead body stay face down like that
on the ground without moving for six
hours like you'd have to be a sociopath
right because he said he had from 10
until I mean how long have they been
there I mean that body's got makeup on
the back yeah
like a sedative or something how can you
be the calm doctor guy when your wife
and kid are out there thinking about
that I am thinking about that
oh my God
[Laughter]
Aaron's gonna give me a freaking heart
attack oh my goodness
what is there something there no thank
you
oh
he was home oh he's home okay
I'm in a bad dream again
just gotta finish this paragraph
I imagine it's the Kool-Aid man in the
room
oh yeah
have to go to work sweetheart
you know what daddy's job is like now
come on you know Daddy has to collect
those bands
[Music]
you're happy I am happy that is complete
[__]
oh and it's probably your wallet he lets
you keep your wallet though I mean it's
not useful at this point it was nice of
him that's kind look at him keeping his
wallet you can take his money
beautiful
so where's the lucky wife there's
another pitcher behind the one you're
looking at it
oh God does he know oh
my God oh God
x marks the spot sometimes you see more
with your eyes shut ah this photo you're
talking about is not here we're just
gonna keep the Polaroid of his family
huh
that's messed up
you're creepy that's the Lost guy was it
it looks like his eye
it really looked like the Lost guy's eye
what is in a sheet
oh why is that so terrifying that he's
just in standing there in a blanket I
hate it I hate it
[Music]
poor girl that little girl is a great
little actor she's going through hell I
believe her
oh
wait
that's not
is it Danny Glover yeah so wait what's
going on now why is he there what's
happening I am so confused why does he
have the camera and he's looking
what I never should have let you go oh
missing person discovered at bizarre
Museum oh did he walk into the guy's
apartment what's what's going on I'm so
confused here Alibi it holds up
meaning like
like what an amazing story that poor
woman told we keep jumping around with
the events so is this happening while
the families get kidnapped no I think
this is a flashback a flashback within
the flashback we arrested at Dennis last
week we like to play with kids a bit too
much he lived two blocks from here the
sewer lines run under this neighborhood
too because present day is what's
happening in the room right but this is
a flashback but the also the his family
getting captured is a flashback too yes
remember 118th Street
k2k that game's territory was only about
four blocks now listen to this
is that a bell
is that a school like sounds like check
the directions for all the fire
emergencies that occurred in that area
within the last two weeks two 13 stygian
Street
okay let's figure it out dang this makes
me want Krispy Kreme though but I cannot
eat it during this movie no way in hell
laughs
I love how Danny Glover holds guns in
movies
always ass out
arm stretched ass out that's funny
oh it's a replica of the guys
all of the traps she's ever
done to this point must be right it's
like
I'm gonna fight this movie ah what is
that thing
nope
oh my god oh it's a guy
oh
why we got him
that saw is gonna go and it's gonna
screw into his head y'all
no don't pull the thing I feel like oh
God oh God oh awake already Jeff
powerful track for tranquilizers next
time you're a test subject for something
greater than yourself
get him get him come on now get him
no [__]
now you'll make a choice just two of you
kill him and then save him okay he will
unlock it where is it you're frustrating
shoot him and make him do it don't play
his game
[Music]
you have The High Ground what are you
guys doing giving in demands right now
for the life of another human being
take his hood off come on now
there it is thank you thank you
oh
my goodness
junk yeah you guys come on now you're
being dumb you're being dumb movie
characters oh my God not this is not
good ideas why would you give him enough
time to
okay
I don't trust these cops anymore I don't
think they're good at their job you
should have shot him when you had the
chance you had the perp there
just shoot him thank you
like that might not be that might have
been some
decoy yeah
no no don't do it don't do it oh no
no no no
oh yeah
no head
what is going on
that's what you guys get for being dumb
not the freeze frame so now because the
killer used the word tranquilizer I
don't think that guy in the room is dead
I think you're right
[Music]
oh he's lost his mind right now
turn off the lights
oh it might glow good idea
yeah x marks the spot there we
what I want to know is why these two
guys specifically in the same room
because this is his right first not this
I guess his first two alive person trap
well now the other guy was alive with
the girl but this is like a man versus
Man Trap
that's the keys too oh yeah
don't if it freaking bounces and or a
door or something I'm gonna be so mad
I think you got it
is there another gun
or is it another bullet
a cell phone and a lighter and
cigarettes is that cigarettes in there
most beautiful invention on this planet
are you guys hopeful as if he hasn't
coordinated this whole thing make that
second most beautiful invention
are you serious dude the cigarettes are
harmless I promise smoking is only
poisonous when it ends in Bloodshed I'm
trying the police
no one said the phone had signal This
was meant to receive calls not make them
this is
this is four last night I'm sure someone
else was there
oh he's in the car the whole time
oh my God what is this what is that
oh my God is that that weird pig mask I
think it is what the
oh my God this is Ah hell to the no to
the no no no no no no no no no no no
that's what gotta be here
that's what got him here we still know
nothing about the other guy we know
nothing about that other guy yeah you're
right we don't
here it is where did you get this it was
in your wallet
what are you doing
he's gonna be like I'm gonna get the gun
in the bullet and I'm gonna kill Adam
you don't need a gun to kill him when
there's that much poison in your blood
oh
so he could put the
you say the cigarette in the gun I was
like in the no in the blood because the
blood is poisonous and maybe it explodes
no this is all wrong I'm just like what
in the is this
there has to be
yeah like put it in the blood but what
is it gonna oh oh and then give it to
him
you still want that cigarette
terrible so bad the worst actor I've
killed him with the poison just like you
wanted now where's my family hello what
the f that's electrocuted the chain
oh nope
can't outsmart him
you guys know you gotta cut your foot
off have we not learned the lesson from
him from Eminem you're gonna break the
other Solitude you guys are so dumb you
said it out loud doctor he wants us to
saw through our feet what are you doing
I remember how I got here oh now we get
to see your story okay
[Applause]
a photographer interesting
oh what
what what
[Music]
maybe he's not working for jigsaw but
maybe the wife because she suspected the
husband of cheese oh right that she was
like go take pictures I didn't
understand that last shot why there was
like a peephole or like a yeah I think
they're trying to mislead us thinking it
was related to the other crime from
earlier with the guy with who got set on
fire
someone there
[Laughter]
killing me I think it's the tricycle
she's sitting there yeah
[Music]
oh he only had he had deal six to kill
him so now he's like 20 minutes right oh
God now it's on
Diana
I'm scared Daddy
oh
everybody ruined here yeah
there's another gun there's two of them
there's more than one person because one
person's watching them while other ones
with the family oh yeah is Adam there
how do you know how do you know Adam
don't believe Adam's lies oh what he
knows you
he knew all about you before today
because you might be right but if you
don't call that did I just call that but
why would she say his lies how does she
know he is lying like did she I think
maybe the guy
told her to say that yeah it's a great
mistrust
who are you you know who I am stop the
line
[Applause]
what did you do last night Lawrence oh
work at a hospital yeah saving sick
children he's the investor yep called
the baby you don't recall getting your
picture taken in that parking lot
are you the pictures that the whole time
I get paid to take pictures of rich guys
like you who go to CD out of the way
motels they're secretaries had these
with you the whole time
found them in there with the hacksaws oh
it's out of curiosity what did you do in
that motel room
get out of there pretty fast
um
secretary yeah nursing student what's
wrong with me to make you come here but
I thought we I'm sorry
it's for you I know what you're doing he
knows what he's doing but is it because
he knows because of the guy's pictures
because of Adam's pictures or he's just
also following him he's also following
him yeah the person who paid you to
follow me who was it he calls himself
Bob and he gives me the money up front
what did he look like now he's a guy
he's a tall black guy he's got a scar
around his neck okay
Clover you could have started with that
[Laughter]
I don't know what he looks like he's
just a tall black guy with a scar like
yeah what detected up he was discharged
from the police force the guy became
obsessed convinced himself that I must
have somehow been involved with the
murders I mean it's crazy
what are you more pissed off about the
fact that I took some shots of you or
the fact that I took some shots of you
while you were cheating on your wife
oh my God
oh you remember something else oh you
see something else what what are you
saying
oh he's in the picture
I know him
zap
what oh God what we're out of time
what happens now
happens now well he said he would kill
oh
I was doing this from their house what
Dr Gordon's time is up I'm afraid it has
to be you that tells him he failed
you son of a [__]
so Barky
you failed
oh yeah girl get it get it get it get it
stay on the ground bro
you should give me the phone let me get
your neck cut like Danny Glover come on
where are you
I know I'm being held captive in a room
somewhere please forgive me I've always
been
happy
well we all saw that coming a bunch of
dummies in this some people's [__] bro I
swear
my goodness
got him
wait how how is he right there oh he's
just was obsessed watching them the
whole time I guess so okay well how is
he so close and ready and available
was he like in the apartment next door
or something from us
he must be
[Applause]
then why was he having him take the
pictures of the doctor before he even
got kidnapped
yes
I'm gonna kill your husband now Mrs
Gordon
that's the cartoony little yeah and
Kelly husband now a little dog too
I didn't know why he was so close I
oh my goodness dang now who's doing this
to you is it on a timer it's helper oh
maybe a timer who is your helper is it
the dead guy on the floor
it's weird that this guy hasn't just
killed Danny right now right because he
sees him in the car driving up right he
could just like so but who electrocuted
him timer might be right or like a
helper well it's a helper get the box
and scrape the phone to you we have the
technology
yeah you can also take off your
button-up shirt
as that guy did
your shirt take your shirt off oh my
goodness take it off come on
all right
I literally had a gunfight Joe to
another location to continue the gun
fight yeah
we're just gonna have to sire leg off I
mean he's a doctor he's gonna know how
to cut off the circulation so maybe
maybe he'll use his shirt to cut the
circulation I'm sure he will
listen to you yeah there we go there we
go
this is dumb
I knew he's gonna do that but he could
also use the shirt to grab the phone you
could be phoning it up and cutting your
leg off at the same time buddy
also I don't know if that was a tight
enough tie with that shirt I'll be
honest
[Laughter]
he didn't have to do that guys you
didn't have to
you didn't have to die oh he really
didn't retired man I absolutely could
have you're too old for this [__] yeah
he didn't have to do that you could have
just grabbed the phone guy
you get through to him
it's all right I've called the police
[Music]
it's the rules
what
was this part of the plan I don't know
oh yeah good good yeah
Adam is the only one with good ideas
oh my God finally somebody kill this guy
oh my God no don't try and stop him okay
guys and bloody white shirts
[Music]
the phone y'all get the phone get the
phone the freaking phone y'all there's a
phone in there
we still don't have an explanation for
why Danny Glover was taking so close
yeah we don't
oh
so far
tape recorder hello Mr Handle or as they
called you around the hospital
I want you to make a choice
[Music]
slow acting poison coursing through your
system which only I have the antidote
for will you murder a mother and her
child to save yourself
uh
uh so we still don't know the guy yet
he's part of the game
called it I called it
oh no oh
no
oh my God
[Music]
oh my God who the f is this oh my God
oh boy oh okay
to that chain
is in the bathtub what what oh Daddy's
sink in that light
in the light thing
[Music]
it's a very interesting person I knew it
oh cause he knew his name hello Mark
Paul Amanda
I want to play a game
[Music]
most people are so ungrateful to be
alive but not you game over
oh my God that guy's just gonna be
locked in the room with and like I
starved to death whoa
whoa did he make it to the other guy
make it to his family
which guy oh that guy there's no way he
bled to death but he was crawling out
maybe there's no way there is oh my god
oh wow I can't with this
I cannot no thank you I knew it was the
guy on the floor oh my God
oh my God cause he was there but then no
one was ever paying attention to them
and they always had reverse yeah like
yes exactly but I want you to forget
about him I also thought that like maybe
they which one's the volume to this this
thing
I also thought that maybe they um
that they like from in my brain I was
like oh they're probably cutting around
the extras so they didn't this is that a
live guy didn't have to lie there every
time they had footage oh right but I
think you're more right because the guy
would just be like I'm getting paid just
lay there and like look dead but that
would be like tough you thought it was
like a logistical thing I did like to
have him there the whole time and you
know he looks real because I looked a
few times to be like do we think that
that might be a dummy for some shots and
it's not it's always a real obviously a
real body and I was like oh it'd
probably be a lot to have them either
yeah probably both it probably is wrong
there yeah well I I also think it would
just be hard for like because if he
breathes at all right you're having a
guy lay there and just be like don't
move at all I would hate that job oh my
gosh okay so tell me your thoughts
initial like initial first thoughts what
are you feeling my initial first
thoughts on my feeling I'm feeling
shocked I'm feeling yeah like that was a
ride we just went on that was a roller
coaster I Now understand why this is a
10 movie franchise yeah right that was
crazy I'm also I'm like wow how did I go
so long like this movie's like what 20
plus years old yes I knew nothing about
it this entire time that was crazy yeah
me neither I think it's like crazy too
that this movie obviously there's a
reason it probably blew up became viral
became like a name
but everyone loves it and at the same
time I get it's the the classic Trope of
horror movie dummy Dum Dum Dums who
never kill the killer that I want to
strangle it was so frustrating just
shoot
the so easy it's right there oh my God
but still like really liked it even
mixed with the frustration but also I'm
like
why was Danny Glover so close to the
house is it just because he was obsessed
so it would make sense if he was
obsessed because he's been stalking that
guy assume that guy had something to do
with it yeah but why would Danny hire
the guy to take the pictures that part
we never got answers to maybe maybe in
the sequel we find out but yeah that
part is kind of a hole that we have that
hasn't been filled yeah
like oh my God ah my favorite part is
seeing the guy get up in the background
and you're like
oh my goodness also that little girl 10
out of 10. so good she is really good
and I know that the mom the blonde hair
I forget her name she worked a lot it
probably still works now I just haven't
seen her in a while she worked a lot and
like when was this made like early 2000s
or late 90s or something maybe 2000 2004
or somewhere around that I like her too
I mean everybody in this movie movie is
actually legitimately really good I
believed everyone uh and oh the pig why
did it have to have hair
why does it have to have a full head of
hair pigs have hair sometimes terrifying
a wig no they don't awful the one pig
that came up that kill him in the garage
is like full head of hair
I can't be doing that I didn't realize
the pig thing was from Saw because I've
been to like horror nights and stuff and
seen the guy with the pig but I never
put it together if it was from this
movie Pig with a wig now we know
what was your favorite part oh man I
think my favorite part might have been
uh the whole scene where Danny Glover
and his partner went to see the guy and
he had like the ass poking I thought
that was funny
[Laughter]
oh but yeah his favorite part of saw was
Danny Glover's butt out while holding a
gun it looks so ridiculous it's
hilarious oh man I don't know the whole
thing was just like a ride like I like
the the non-linear storytelling because
like you're putting pieces together as
like the characters are and just you're
just it leaves you on the edge of your
seat until the very end and you're like
I don't know what's going on they don't
know what's going on we're out here on
this ride together I'm scared they're
scared but yeah I just
yeah it was wild and like has you
frustrated with the characters as
they're trying to figure it out too and
yeah it makes me excited I was like dang
I want to see the rest of them yeah
because I I from the little I do know
it's like they're kind of treated as
like chapters I think something without
a fact yeah but I don't know like
anything that happens within those
chapters I just know that
um yeah obviously the the main killer is
is revealed at the end so obviously he's
gonna probably be in the other ones
right um oh my God but I did I think I
called out even though it was like my
brain was getting there when we read
that the cigarettes are not poisonous
something about poisonous and then we
heard the blood the poison in the blood
and that's why he dabbed the cigarette
and the blood to maybe give it to Adam
to smoke and then he would maybe die
that needs to be revealed to me yeah
well I think that right they were kind
of saying at the end is that the guy who
was jigsaw he was sick so maybe his
blood blood was poisonous yeah because
he's like poison coursing through my
veins but I also was like but why was
the letter saying something poisonous
linked with the cigarettes even though
it kept saying they're not why was it
that thing was like a that's the part of
a jigsaw that we haven't unlocked yet I
would like to read that note again and
be like what was the link why did he dip
the cigarette in the blood then because
I think he thought it would kill him
because he's because the note said that
there was a kill right yes yes because
he is so and then he gave adam the other
one to not kill him yeah right okay but
still uh
there I just I don't know I'm mad at the
characters that went in and they didn't
kill him right away no I do love that of
course the smart one in this is the mom
who's like let's get untied we hear him
coming
fake it fake it girl thank you she's not
great because she has the gun and can
shoot him and like she stays close to
him these are the parts that I'm like uh
I hate this I hate this move away from
him grab your daughter or shoot him in
the leg if you don't want to kill a man
shoot him in the leg like come on now
what are we doing here and also hang up
with your husband and call 9-1-1 thank
you like why are you like what do you
mean you're locked in a room what does
that mean I'm like girl look at you like
you're locked in her room with your kid
what do you mean is that confusing for
you like these things
I go through it you see me you see I'm
going through a downward spiral right
now I get so mad at these characters but
it was still very entertaining super
entertaining like so freaking good
um I give it okay we'll give it 10 out
of 10 stars
um I'll give it
I mean that was fun it was fun I also
want to see more of the little replicas
I'm gonna give it like I'm gonna give it
a 7.7 out of 10 even though those those
characters made me mad this was this was
fun this was thrilling the entire time I
really dug the Intrigue and the Mystery
the dumb character moves take it down a
couple points I think for me I'd give it
an eight because that's good I was gonna
go eight but then I was like don't scare
dang make me mad Maybe so mad I just
want I just want I want this movie like
if they made it again for characters to
be smarter but the killer to still get
away yes right like he's shot and he's
like limping but he figures out like oh
I don't know I don't know you guys I
don't really have the solution but like
uh this was fun we'll have to watch the
other ones there's like a million more
oh yeah so we're in it you guys gotta
let us know what you think do you guys
want us to watch the rest of the saws
probably you guys are probably gonna be
like absolutely yes don't forget to
leave a like leave a comment comment
tell us what we missed in this little
please yeah because maybe we're confused
by something that you guys picked up and
exactly I'm just trying to get the
answers but don't spoil please because
we want to watch the other ones no
spoilers about any of the other ones
guys only comment about what we have
said here today or of the saw number one
okay and also if you're not already
patreon you should become one and and
pledge up because then you could watch
all the reactions all of it the whole
the whole thing the whole Gambit with me
the whole thing okay so just get on it
we love you so much and yeah I mean
we'll see you we'll see you soon see you
soon bye
foreign
[Music]